children with autism they're lacking in
empathy emotional empathy which you know
must involve many neurons they are
unable to adopt somebody else's point of
view on a conceptual and a conceptual
level possibly even at a conceptual
level and because also it's something
that you ascribe it's this function to
mirror neurons that's missing in autism
at impoverished in autism so the lack of
emotional empathy there's also lack of
pretend play pretend play by definition
in normal children not autistic children
requires that you put yourself in the
shoes of that doll with an action figure
pretend you're Superman suspend reality
for a short while
pretend you're Superman this autistic
children are incapable of doing is
undoubtedly one of the functions of
mirror neurons you need to tap into
mirror neurons in order to put yourself
in the shoes of the action figure and
also sophisticated imitation which is
missing in many autistic to learn
another function of mirror neurons
impoverished language is something that
you see on 216 or so we make a list of
all the properties emotional empathy
theory about the minds imitation pretend
play and you look at all those functions
of metal neurons and make a time Euler
column of the functions that are
deficient in autism there's almost a
perfect fit this is what led us to
suggest over ten years ago or maybe
about ten years ago that mirror neuron
dysfunction might be the basis of autism
I'd be one of the major causes of autism
now there's several groups which have
shown this to be true during brain
imaging but there's one group who claims
they don't seem in a neuron deficit so
what I'm arguing is this is highly
speculative at this point I would say
their evidence is suggestive but not
compelling or per se or persuasive but
not compelling so we have to wait and
see
the question is as a mariner on system
completely drained or there is there
some residual activity still there and I
suspect the simplicity of activity and
can you tap into this activity by using
biofeedback you know there are a EEG
signals associated with mirror neurons
and mirror neuron deficiency so can the
patient be taught to enhance by watching
the computer screen but using
biofeedback and hence the EEG signal
that by indirectly recruiting more
neurons and enhancing the activity
mirror neurons this is still very
experimental but people are trying it
the other possibility is mirror neuron
systems may have specific transmitters
associate with them it wouldn't be
surprising for example before them we
all know that e enhances ecstasy
enhances empathy it is quite possible as
acting through the mirror neuron system
especially parts of the mirror neuron
system that are in the that are in the
insular cortex and parts of the mirror
neuron system that are concerned with
emotional empathy so maybe if you knew
what transmitters were involved you can
engineer drugs that tap into that and
enhance activity of mirror neurons Isham
another way is to do exercises by
synchronized dancing like Rockettes
using multiple mirror reflections to
enhance activity of mirror neurons all
of this is hypothetical and purely
speculative unlikely to work but worth
trying